[Music]
International chess professionals
converge in st. Louis for the 2017
spring chess classics happy Friday
everybody and welcome back to the 2017
spring chest classic today saw round
four four groups a and B and round five
for Group C some players are now
logically eliminated from contention for
top place but there's still half of this
tournament to be played the 2017 spring
chess classic features a combined prize
fund of more than 50 grand win the top
prize in Group A that will get you
$6,000 $4,000 is the prize for Group B
and the top prize for Group C is $5,000
that's because Group C is actually
stronger than Group B at the top of
Group A Jeffrey Zhang has a new buddy
and his name is Sandro Mariko the
argentinian Grandmaster who today with
the black pieces defeated grandmaster
conscious feeling so it's good to have
you here for the first time thank you
for joining me and Sandra this is your
first tournament in the United States
ever right yeah the first tournament
because I never come to United States
before is the first time in United say
or how did you get hooked up with this
tournament yeah for me was very good to
be invited to play here because I never
play in a tournament like that
normally I don't play closest
tournaments and I never played on a man
of these extremes
well this is a pretty strong tournament
take us through your victory today over
catches really he play ruga for I think
I'm H Phi also but he comes here and I
don't see nothing special to do here for
that reason i takes take and 96 he here
if he change that one 94 here i have a
night if i maybe maybe sequel position
again but i don't have any problem right
here we play rock c4 but I think that
this was good because I have Brooke age
five
he's a strange but bad maybe works what
he plays 23 rock age 5
yeah here here maybe I'm better because
I'm training Bishop e5 and if she plays
came here I had a lot of possibilities
but here I have bra here booger hey I
have a lot of possibilities and I'm and
well here and also also possible to take
stakes on 95 takes only 2 and this but
ok all the positions are ok thing for me
but he play nicely for and here I play
Bishop e5 it's complicated because looks
like you have root X but it's not so
fantastic because I have this move
because if I take she take some I have
problems with this rock for that reason
and here yeah here I think and also in
this g3 but after she 3 I think you know
rook f8 also possible to play Kinichi
but I think that this is possible
ok afraid I'm here if he takes I think
in on that move because I trained him
rook F 2 and also to take the rooks the
rogue and if he play for example Roxy
for I have this I think that I'm better
if she plays like that I think that I
have takes because if he takes I have
this and if if he plays like that I have
this move also training this and maybe
we'll be winning here if he plays takes
ITEX can i turn in the rook and also
here for example if he plays like that I
think that I have this mode these this
check I went here and also the other
mode will be possible protein is like
that but I think that I am brighter here
yeah it's always to complicate the
position yeah but I feel that maybe I
invited after in this position he takes
here Bishop takes yeah maybe
here I feel very well because it's
difficult to play for him and always I
have a perpetual checks or some kind of
trade like Queen f7 to play Bishop d3
and rook h1 for that my training is
Queen f7 Bishop three three row gauge
one and some mate but he played rook and
I play rook c8 because this rook was a
very good role for him for that reason
rogue f5 rook
yeah during the game ping him on e4 also
but here I think that maybe Bishop c5
these these this here and this I think
that maybe I am winning here I don't see
nothing for him maybe he's up something
but I don't see I didn't see nothing
feel because I have a lot of traits and
I feel that maybe she's lost here but
yeah he plays three three and after
takes here this is not possible to take
because check and mate if we play for
example like that I come here and he
don't come nothing to do because we need
three win come here here yeah here is
yeah these don't works in the only move
but because rook F 2 is made but here
here and I'm mr. Keeney saving he lost
some time bad but the position he don't
come nothing to do more because check in
da damn I come with the King here to a7
on is totally waiting for me that's all
she wrote Sandra you mentioned that you
had a very busy schedule recently in the
chess world and you're taking a break
from chess for a little bit tell us
about no I play a lot of tournaments in
a row before that I play try tournaments
I think and after that maybe I try to to
train a lot for the warchest cups
because I qualify a few days before
coming here I qualify in the soma
tournament in Argentina
pretty cool well good luck in that and
the rest of this tournament of course
because he's at the top of the
leaderboard group a Sandra Mariko so
let's take a look at the standings after
four rounds and then played in Group A
even though we have two at the top every
player in Group A is still within
striking distance the results have been
pretty even thus far
here are your pairings for Saturday May
20 and Sunday May 21 keep an eye on
boards 1 and 2 on Saturday as young and
Morocco respectively have white and then
on Sunday on board 5 Jong and Morocco
play each other in what is sure to be
the key game of the day we'll have a
weekend recap video for you up Sunday
night my guest at this time from Group B
JJ Ali Morandi Turkish
International Master today you had the
black pieces and walked away with a win
over International Master Abdul Malik
so congratulations thank you take us
through the game and show us what
happened
I was happy after BC BC and g5 because
it she would take 94 bishop here night
digs digs
kink digs and I was thinking g3 and I
wasn't sure what's going on because if
white captures I take check and look at
seven and she can to protect age to end
the Queen at the same time and there is
no check on before because the Knights
protect me so everything was working out
perfectly for me but after g3 I was
thinking I would play something like
Bishop e6 I'm threatening 93 and maybe
I'm better because I can't really play
93 now she takes and there is like
perpetual from music so I wasn't really
very sure about it same goes for Queen
b6 King h1 and yeah so I can really go
for the exchange because takes here same
thing are you after here okay so now
Queen b6 it's very unclear if I take
it's probably like I draw I don't know
maybe even better for light after this
so I wasn't really sure what's going on
but Bishop e6 should be good enough h3 I
was a little surprised night 87 I
actually don't know if this is a good
move because I I thought I could play
Queen a5 some reason I was calculating
on the Bishop b2 where III just wins
because if Queen takes Bishop before I
just pin the queen of the King and the
bishop takes the c3 Knight is hanging
but she can play Knight a4 as she said
after the game or even 92 which I was
thinking and why it's actually fine
because if I take and wipe this cute
rescue the real funny one
so I played Bishop f6 so please I'm
trying to play on the G file maybe bring
my queen to g7 put some pressure on the
long diagonal like that and I just want
to use the G file rook c1 I was slightly
surprised I was expecting rook e1 maybe
to bring the rook on the seventh but
really it's not easy to play because I
can go Queen a5 let's say and she can't
really move the knight this time because
after I take any captures and night on
here's an h4 time so if she has to play
that I have the ideas with e3 here as
well so that's why she didn't believe
would be one she played rooks you want
with the idea to protect the knight on
c3 by attack it she can just defend with
they should be three that's the whole
concept but I really wasn't looking at
the Queen side at this point I wanted to
use the G file put the rooks on Queen
I'm she's trying to build a fortress
with g3 Knight g2 otherwise so I just
play whatever and I'm maybe better
because my idea was like to play Queen
here Queen afraid maybe if I can get
this that would be great but she will
just play G 392 Knight G 2 and she would
be fine so I play rugby 8 maybe I'll use
the B file as well work on a8 wasn't
going much this should be 3 and well
okay now the bishop is kind of useless
28 I'm threatening to go to h5 g3 now I
can't really go to h5 because she can
play here and I can actually go back and
I'm still fine of course but I just
played Queen f7 not showing my
intentions maybe I'll double on the G
file with rooks
or I might play Queen g7 so I have two
main ideas
engage - I decided to double and she was
very low on time she had like a minute
or two and it was move 26 so I thought I
had to bring more pieces into the game
why plane ig5 I'm not very certain if
this sacrifices winning close to winning
or even good but my intuition told me
that it cannot be so bad because
basically all white pieces are stuck and
they're not doing much so even if I'm a
piece down just for a pawn and if I'm
attacking with her load time I should be
fine 92 this was actually good I was
expecting rook f1 honestly and not g1
but this is like very fast if I can just
play route k7 try to double on the edge
file and I have like all the time in the
world so she played knight of for trying
to please exchange some pieces but I I
wanted to keep everything on the board
Maya def 3 was a threat they should be 1
would be 2 now I invade it also on the
second King gauge one night of three six
six and this is pretty much lost but
because the idea is which X this after
the game but now I have my bishop on d7
finally working after a foreign Bishop
h6 coming ninety six six six Green h5
this was a nice mate
okay they check Knight h4 and g4 is me
because the road finally works knowledge
for I took okay this is like resignation
maybe g4 was better try but bus is also
long this she resigned because after
takes Queen f3 check and okay that's it
so with two and a half points
you're a point in half behind the leader
in Group B we're virtually at the
halfway point it at this point in time
after Round four what do you see your
chances are for taking Group B at this
point well I tried to play every game at
a time and not really consider the
standings
of course I'll do my best to catch up to
leaders but I already played with one of
them and I lost yesterday so totally in
your hands anymore yeah so I'll be doing
my best in the upcoming rounds
I have like five more games right so I
mean everything can change in this vibe
round of course now also you won the ICC
open the open of the Internet pardon me
the Internet Chess Club which is the
original pay servers for online chess
which is amazing tell us a little bit
about that well it's very nice to win
such an open how many players were
nothing it was first a qualification
event there were nine different
qualifiers for four spots and nine or
maybe eight I'm not very certain I think
it would be and after that
the players qualified and there were
like knockouts and eliminations and I
actually knocked out five GM's to win
the event very cool so in the qualifier
I actually qualified relatively easy
scoring nine and a half out of eleven
and that was actually enough to qualify
and in the knockout stages it was quite
self because the match format it was
like a match was for game match against
Club p.m. and after I won the first game
I actually thought I could maybe win the
event I was confident because online
it's different than playing over the
board what was the time control the
knockout phase was three plus all but on
the final only there was a ten game
match with 3 + 0 + 3 + 2 5 games of 3 +
0 + five games of 3 poster so after I
got through the 3 plus 0 time control
and playing the final I mean I was at
least confident that I could do
something I mean after coming to the
final as possible and I will win the
event well that's pretty cool I've got
to admit I've been kind of off the radar
when it comes to the ICC it for the past
2 years so that's awesome to hear that
you won that so congratulations today JJ
thank you so much
JJ Ally mirandy middle the pack in Group
B speaking of Group E let's take a look
at those standings after four rounds
have been played the game of the day for
Saturday May 20 has to be board number 4
I wonder Liang taking on Alexander
Lenderman the two leaders meet each
other on Sunday board number three as
Christian korilla takes on a wonder leg
at the time of this recording both
players set a top of the leaderboard
with 4 out of 4
someone's Oh in the losing column that
is has got to go Group C is all about
Illya News NIC and Sam seve on on
Saturday May 20 if the showdown we've
been waiting for as the two leaders face
off on board number one and below that
round seven for Group C is Sunday May 21
stay with us through Wednesday May 24th
as every round begins at 1:00 p.m. with
the exception of the final day see the
move by move live as it happens at chest
24 calm and us chest champs calm